- [Instructor] Talk a little
bit about what could cause
a supply or a demand curve
for a currency to shift.
So here we have the
foreign exchange market
for the Chinese yuan which
is why we have the quantity
of yuan on the horizontal axis
and the price of the yuan in terms
of another currency on the vertical axis
and here that other
currency is the US dollar.
And associated with, let's
just call this S sub one,
our supply curve, and D
sub one, our demand curve,
you have at the intersection
an equilibrium point.
We have talked about this in other videos.
Let's call that e sub one.
This would be some
dollar price for a yuan.
Maybe it's 10 US cents per yuan.
And then associated that is also
an equilibrium quantity, Q sub one.
That would be a certain amount
of yuan that is trading hands
in a certain time period,
whatever the time period
this graph or this model applies to.
So one big way to think about
what would influence supply
and demand is think about
who holds the supply,
and then who is demanding that currency.
So if we're thinking about the
market for the Chinese yuan,
the supply is going to be
from people who hold yuan,
so people who hold yuan.
And for the most part,
that's going to be people in the country.
It's possible that someone
sitting in New York
has a yuan denominated account
or has some yuan sitting in their wallet,
but for the most part it's going
to be people in the country.
So motivated for the most part
by what happens in China,
what happens in China.
And on the other hand, if
we're thinking about demand,
it's the other way around.
These would be other
people that for some reason
want to convert their currency,
their non-yuan currency, into the yuan,
so people who hold other currencies,
other currencies like the US dollars.
And so this tends to be motivated.
It's possible that someone
in Beijing is holding dollars
or has a dollar bank account,
but for the most part
it's going to be motivated
by other countries.
And so for example, if
we think about supply,
what could shift the supply to the right
or could increase supply?
So shifting to the supply
means more Chinese want
to sell their yuan,
they want to convert it
into something else, let's say US dollars.
And so this could be
an increase in demand,
so increase in demand for foreign,
you could say goods,
services, or assets.
In this case, it might
be an increase in demand
for American goods, services, or assets.
They might want American assets
because they get a better return there.
Or maybe they view them
as safer investments.
Maybe they want to send their children
to an American college so there's a demand
or there's an increase in
demand for sending kids
to the American colleges,
so that's a service.
Maybe they are interested in
buying more American cars.
Another thing that could
increase the demand for,
say, American goods, is
if there's a decrease
in tariffs on those things.
So those things have
become cheaper in China.
So any of these things
could shift the supply curve
to the right, this is S sub two.
And then associated with that,
we would have a new equilibrium
exchange rate, e sub two,
and a new equilibrium quantity
that is changing hands.
And notice, the price of
the yuan has now gone down
as people are demanding, in
this case, more American goods.
And of course, if we
switched the arrows here,
if we had a lower demand for,
let's say, American goods,
services, and assets,
then the supply curve
would shift to the left, and the yuan
would become more expensive
in terms of dollars.
And so on the demand side, it
works the other way around.
What could shift the
demand curve to the right?
Let's call this D three right
over here to right over here.
Let's assume that the supply
curve has not been shifted.
So this would go to e sub three.
So the yuan has become more
expensive, and that makes sense.
More people are demanding it.
And we have a different quantity now.
Let's call that Q sub three.
But what would cause it
to shift in that way?
So demand for yuan
would go up,
if you have an increase in demand
for Chinese goods from foreigners.
Chinese goods, actually I should say
services or assets.
So if you have an increase
in the number of Americans
who were holding dollars
or are holding dollars,
and say hey, I could get a better return
if I invest in China.
Maybe it's growing faster.
And so I want to convert
my dollars into yuan.
I want to buy yuan with my dollars
so I could participate in
the Chinese stock market
or buy shares or somehow
buy some Chinese real estate
or whatever else it might be.
And obviously if demand for
Chinese goods, services,
and assets were to go
down, then the demand curve
would shift the other way.